Peggy 12 you see this game right here  yes sir this is mighty number nine and  all that wants to be is fun and  challenging and fun and replayable as  hell and oh did I mention fun bring it  on  and there's a million ways to play this  game you like fighting bosses Oh boss  rush mode  you want to tackle all the challenges we  got on it here's a challenge mode for  you next oh what's that make it harder  you asked for it one hit death maniac  mode but that's just what we call it  you'll be calling it why're you doing  this to me and of course you can go  online and team up or face off against  your friends or strangers or even that  weird dude who lives down the street  who's name is probably Vernon or some  other creepy thing what just happened  dark God lost their check out this  montage  you  and this is all just the beginning so  what are you waiting for  mighty number 9 available februari 12  bring it